ich würde es sehr begrüßen wenn du ein
bisschen weniger mit den gästen
quatschen dafür bisschen schneller
arbeiten könnte oder nächste mal will
sie weniger ausschnitt entschuldigung
ich dachte die gäste sollen sich prüfen
die gäste fühlen sich wohl wenn sie ihre
getränke bekommen also wenn ich weiß
dass du hast die macht das doch
großartig macht ihm nichts aus so will
sind kann man es gar nicht recht machen
niemand kann das außer wenn der fc
endlich mal wieder gewinnt der fc erster
fc köln fußball mädchen ist ja sooo
schlecht also schlechteste machen ich
habe noch eine lerngruppe
entschuldigung
einen milchkaffee täter
also ich weiß nicht was dein chef hat
mach dir nichts draus wegen eben kommen
die gäste bestimmten genau sondern wegen
des guten milchkaffees
ist das denn voll ein
certa
kommst du nicht weiter kann ich dir
helfen
hab versucht zu schlafen aber ich musste
meine mutter denken
auch lotta diabetes ist nichts schönes
aber man kann damit leben
eigentlich schon aber man muss einfach
die ernährung umstellen
meine oma hat sich damals geweigert sie
hat täglich kiloweise träger der aus
gegessen was ist dann das sehr leckere
süßigkeiten mit viel schokolade sie
süchtig danach schließlich hatte auch
augenprobleme deswegen gekriegt aber
deine mutter ist nicht so stur oder
du hast ja recht ich bin nur so schlecht
drauf weil ich so ein schlechtes
gewissen habe dabei hatte ich mich
gerade so darüber gefreut
etwas mehr abstand zu kriegen verstehst
du endlich ein bisschen freiraum endlich
mal durchatmen und schon kann sie wieder
kann er nichts dafür dass sie krank ist
ich bin so eine tochter